sur la ligne rouge pour forcer le destin
mais elle est absolument nécessaire pour
préserver un avenir qui l'a rendu
incertain
à bientôt
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
un président un brésilien janet jackson
à rosny la gravité de la pandémie il a
été élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
m
premier week-end de test codice 19h dans
les aéroports français pour les
voyageurs en provenance de pays à
risques la mesure est entrée en vigueur
hier alors que les indicateurs montrent
une reprise de l'épidémie en france les
autorités appellent à la vigilance
plusieurs centaines
une impose désormais le pont du masque à
l'extérieur la justice israélienne
ordonne à yaïr netanyahu de cesser de
harceler les organisateurs des
manifestations jeudi lé fils du premier
ministre avait twitté leur adresse
personnelle
depuis plusieurs semaines des
rassemblements se déroule presque chaque
jour dans le pays notamment devant le
domicile de benyamin nétanyahou
les protestataires reprochent au chef du
gouvernement sa gestion de la pandémie
ils ont une nouvelle fois hier réclamer
sa démission
donald trump refuse de retirer ses
troupes fédérales de portions de cette
ville du nord-ouest des etats-unis
devenu le symbole de la lutte contre le
racisme et les brutalités policières
de nouveaux heurts ont éclaté cette
semaine entre les forces de l'ordre et
les protestataires qualifiés par le
président américain d'anarchistes et
d'agitateurs
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les tests kobe
19 sont entrées en vigueur hier en
france dans les aéroports parisiens
notamment qui concentre la majorité des
liaisons internationales est ciblé les
voyageurs en provenance de 16 pays jugés
à risque ou la couronne à virus circule
de façon inquiétante
quelques 5 156 passagers ont été testés
ce samedi à roissy et orly
la mesure est désormais obligatoire
autre option présenter un test de
dépistage virologique détend un peu
moins de 72 heures pour éviter une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie le port du
masque est privilégiée
la liste des villes françaises qui
l'imposent ne cesse de s'allonger à
lille nice saint malo biarritz ou encore
69 communes de mayenne dès demain le
port du masque sera imposée dans
certaines zones de centre-ville les
arrêter à se multiplient depuis vendredi
les préfets sont en effet autorisés elle
rendra obligatoire dans les lieux
publics ouverts déclaré comme inutile
dans les rues par le directeur général
de la santé le masque en extérieur est
devenu recommandé par le ministre de la
santé jeudi dernier une nouvelle mesure
qui fait débat parmi les vacanciers au
touquet très bonne mesure j'espère que
d'autres villes
vont avoir le même la même réaction et
porter un masque
c'est une nécessité et même une priorité
bon on fait avec c'est contraignant il
fait chaud à la maison c'est pour la
bonne cause donc ça me dérange pas mais
je trouve ça ridicule donc en marche ici
on met le masque mais on va s'asseoir on
enlève les gens qui mangent des glaces
c'est un peu ridicule
le port du masque en plus avec les
rafales de vent le virus peut très bien
se propager rapidement
et voilà ça coûte pas grand chose entre
ça et éventuellement se retrouver sur un
lit d'hôpital je pense que yama packtec
tous les acteurs accusé d'abus de
faiblesse gérald darmanin avait promis
d'aller jusqu'au bout il a finalement
retiré sa plainte pour dénonciation
calomnieuse
dernier rebondissement dans l affaire
qui oppose le ministre de l'intérieur à
une habitante de tourcoing les faits
remontent à près de deux ans et demi une
tourquennoise accuse celui qui était
alors le maire de sa ville de l'avoir
incité à des relations sexuelles en
échange d'une aide pour obtenir un
logement
la procédure a été classée sans suite au
printemps 2018 selon mediapart le
ministre a retiré sa plainte en octobre
de la même année plainte maintenu en
revanche toujours pour dénonciation
calomnieuse et cette fois ci à
l'encontre d'une autre femme qui
accusait la gérald darmanin de viol
les investigations ont repris mi juin
deux affaires qui suscite la colère des
associations féministes elles demandent
la démission du ministre de l'intérieur
mohamud et l'or et cyrielle bois
[Applaudissements]
ne pas relâcher la pression c'est le
leitmotiv des associations féministes à
l'encontre de gérald darmanin depuis sa
nomination au ministère de l'intérieur
la mobilisation à son encontre ne
faiblit pas pas un déplacement sans
qu'il ne soit chahuter les associations
mettent les bouchées doubles pour faire
démissionner le premier flic de france
dans tout le pays des centaines de
rassemblements ont été organisés pour
dénoncer ce qui est désormais baptisé le
remaniement de la honte
le collectif nous tout a tenté
d'interpeller sur twitter le premier
ministre jean castex
bonjour jean castex votre ministre de
l'intérieur est visé par une enquête
pour viol et a reconnu avoir échangé un
service contre un acte sexuel
en matière d' insulte aux femmes
victimes et de conflits d'intérêts
on pouvait difficilement faire mieux non
gérald darmanin est visé par deux
plaintes
la première en 2009 où il est accusé de
viol par sophie paterson spatz selon la
plaignante darmanin aurait apporté son
appui
en échange de faveurs sexuelles une
relation consentie selon lui cette
affaire est classée sans suite par le
parquet en 2018 la deuxième concerne une
habitante de tourcoing qui affirme avoir
été obligé d'avoir des relations
sexuelles pour un logement hlm en 2015
une enquête préliminaire pour abus de
faiblesse a été classée sans suite le
collectif pouvoir féministe a saisi le
parquet de lille et entend rouvrir les
investigations selon le collectif la
sphère pourrait aller bien plus loin en
dehors de la question du viol et de
l'abus de faiblesse
si les faits sont avérés si gérald
darmanin sollicités ou même accepté un
rapport sexuel avant d'intervenir en
faveur d'une citoyenne il y à ce que
l'on appelle trafic d'influencé
corruption et les abeilles moreno
ministre délégué à l'égalité femmes
hommes étaient attendus sur ce dossier
selon elle la sphère dharmanand est un
boulet au pied mais il faut néanmoins
laisser le bénéfice du doute au ministre
de l'intérieur
j'ai parlé avec monsieur darmanin j'ai
eu une conversation de femme à homme
avec lui je lui ai dit il faut qu'on se
parle là parce qu'on est dans la même
équipe
ton sujet va être un boulet à porter
pour moi il faut que tu m'expliquer ce
qui s'est passé et ce qu'il m'a dit me
porte à le croire
maintenant je veux mais aussi du côté
des personnes dont j'ai la
responsabilité
les femmes et si jamais il va menti j'en
tirerai toutes les conséquences
gérald darmanin a fait à nouveau parler
de lui après ses propos à la veille d'un
déplacement à nice où des tirs ont
éclaté en plein jour il a déclaré qu'il
fallait stopper l'ensauvagement d'une
certaine partie de la société
une formule banalisée par la droite
nationaliste française est dénoncé par
l'ensemble de la gauche y compris dans
la majorité notamment par barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique qui a vivement réagi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ait un gouvernement au
service de tous les français et qu'on
doit rassembler tous les français c'est
le principal monter les français les uns
contre les autres peut toujours être un
risque si gérald darmanin ne fait pas
l'unanimité au sein de la classe
politique
il peut compter sur le soutien de
nicolas sarkozy son ancien mentor
gérald est un ami j'ai pu compter sur sa
fidélité et sa solidité
je suis quelqu'un de fidèle il peut
compter sur mon amitié
je vous demande de bien comprendre ça
sent la présomption d'innocence
il n'y a pas de démocratie le respect de
la présomption d'innocence
je ne le dis pas parce que gérald est un
ami je le dis pour la démocratie
française et pour l'état de droit
emmanuel macron a lui aussi brandit
l'argument de la présomption d'innocence
si l'exécutif réitère son soutien gérald
darmanin à matignon l'entourage de jean
castex a affirmé que s'il enquête
révélée le moindre doute
le ministre de l'intérieur devrait
quitter le gouvernement en attendant la
justice a ordonné en juin la reprise des
investigations sur l'accusation de viol
à son encontre
après une semaine de débats parfois
houleux fpt le projet de loi bioéthique
a été votée à l'assemblée nationale les
députés ont finalement adopté en
deuxième lecture la mesure phare du
texte l'ouverture de la procréation
médicalement assistée à toutes les
femmes
le texte doit encore repasser devant le
sénat
le point en images
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon
o o
les réactions de rémi tales fondateur de
marianne conseil et de maxime minot l'un
des rares députés les républicains
favorables au texte
jamais dans l'histoire parlementaire
récente un texte de loi n'avait tenté
d'introduire de telles modifications
civilisationnel anthropologique de la
vie humaine d'ailleurs des députés la
république en marche
je pense évidemment à la pma son père
mais on pourrait aussi citer la création
d'embryons chimères mi homme mi animal
l'arpa qui est une gpa qui ne dit pas
son nom ou l'extension du diagnostic
préimplantatoire qui est un euphémisme à
peine voilée et tout ça au milieu de
l'été dans un mépris quand même des
parlementaires de l'opposition puisque
le des ministres ont été très très peu
présents et ils ont lorsqu'ils étaient
présents assez assez rarement daigné
répondre aux questions des
parlementaires
donc on a quand même le sentiment d'un
débat confisqué aux français et d'un
texte qui est tout ce feu sauf équilibré
j'ai appris tellement de choses pendant
cette commission spéciale pendant toutes
ses auditions sur la pma pour tout d'une
part des femmes dans un tel désespoir de
vouloir procréer on était amené à
acheter du sperme sur internet et de se
faire d insémination artisanale à la
maison est bien là je dis que
législateur doit intervenir il doit
intervenir tout simplement pour
légaliser tout cela de façon à ce que à
cesser ces risques sanitaires
donc il y a effectivement plein de
facteurs emmanuel macron l'avez
peut-être effectivement mis dans son
campagne dans son plan de campagne pour
les présidentielles mais aujourd'hui
c'est faut mettre de côté la politique
politicienne il faut agir pour la
société est aujourd'hui moi en tant que
député on me demande de faire quoi de
faire une loi juste équitable pour
toutes et pour tous et aujourd'hui j'ai
le sentiment que ça remet sur un pied
d'égalité toutes les femmes
le royaume uni appelle la france à sévir
contre les traversée illégale de la
manche
les autorités britanniques jugent leur
niveau inacceptable jeudi deux sondes
migrants sont parvenus à rejoindre les
côtes anglaises depuis la france à bord
d'une
vingtaine d'embarcations un record ils
étaient au total plus de 1000 à franchir
le détroit sur le seul mois de juillet
pour le secrétaire d'état à
l'immigration les français doivent
prendre des mesures plus fortes
écoutez nombre de traversées à bord de
petites embarcations que nous observons
en provenance de france est inacceptable
et les migrants continuent d'arriver à
calais pour tenter de traverser les
français doivent prendre des mesures
plus fortes et pendu après 102,1 l'omi
avocat au barreau de paris
d'abord ce qui est important de préciser
c'est que et dont peu le savent
l'angleterre ne fait pas partie de
l'espace schengen donc c'est important
puisque l'ensemble des mécanismes qui
existent dans ce cadre là entre les pays
bien ne s'applique pas il y à un traité
qui existent le traité de 230 de 2018
qui a été signé entre les deux pays et
qui permettent aux autorités françaises
et anglaises de coopérer dans ce cadre
là notamment pour les led à l'entrée au
séjour irrégulier d'étrangers mais aussi
en matière d'asile des mineurs puisque
c'est un problème qui est assez vaste
donc ce débat là est un débat qui pose
un problème politique entre les deux
pays d'ailleurs parce qu'en fait la
france a tendance à vouloir s'en
débarrasser à au départ puisque bon ces
personnes qui restent à caler pose
beaucoup de problèmes d'ailleurs la
france a été condamnée par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour le
traitement inhumain et dégradant de des
demandeurs d'asile en france
mais ces personnes qui veulent aller en
angleterre devrait pouvoir s'y rendre
pour certains parce qu'ils ont de la
famille là-bas
cette direction en israël qu un tribunal
de jérusalem ordonne ce dimanche au fils
du premier ministre de cesser de
harceler les organisateurs des
manifestations réclamant le départ de
son père ils étaient encore des milliers
hier rassemblés devant la résidence
officielle de benyamin nétanyahou pour
réclamer sa démission
la plus grande manifestation du genre
nicolas début de ce mouvement de
protestation il ya plusieurs semaines
maintenant en soutien à son père il ya
ira netanyahu avait twitté jeudi à les
adresses personnelles des organisateurs
appelant à manifester en retour devant
les maisons des protestataires
inculpé de corruption le premier
ministre israélien est également
contesté pour sa gestion de la crise du
corner gouvernement israélien n'a pas
réussi à gérer la crise du coronavirus
le premier ministre fait face à de
graves accusations de corruption et
surtout la démocratie israélienne est en
danger parce que nous sommes limités
dans notre droit de protester nous
sommes exposés à une violence extrême
les gens en israël en ont assez et quand
ils sortent manifester ils sont
confrontés à une violence très dur je
pense que le gouvernement a échoué dans
tous les pays normaux quiconque échoue
rentrer chez lui et donne une chance à
quelqu'un d'autre et c'est pourquoi ils
devraient rentrer chez eux tout le
gouvernement
ce n'est pas seulement netanyhou lé
premier ministre il est le chef et tout
le monde doit rentrer chez lui et nous
donner une autre chance pour un meilleur
gouvernement qui dénonce celui des actes
de violence et de harcèlement de tous
il accuse la presse locale de se
mobiliser contre lui
je condamne toute violence elle n'a pas
sa place de quelque côté que ce soit et
nous n'avons aucune tolérance à l'égard
de toute violence ou menaces de violence
mais au nom de la démocratie
je vois plutôt une tentative de piétiner
la démocratie lorsque les manifestants
arrivent avec des torches et menacent de
lancer des cocktails molotov sur la
résidence du premier ministre
le rôle des médias est également à
blâmer les manifestants disent que s'il
n'était pas dans sa résidence officielle
il ne serait pas nécessaire de protester
il y à une incitation sauvage et sans
entraves provoquant des appels
quotidiens pour assassiner le premier
ministre et sa famille les médias
l'ignorent et le couvre et les
politiciens restent silencieux et le
regard de michel rambo ancien
ambassadeur de france
bon ça fait un moment qu'il est
effectivement là ce n'est pas la justice
et jusqu'à présent a réussi à s'en tirer
malgré encore une fois les trois chefs
d'accusation pas typo corruption od
confiance et puis les deux aussi des
ligues majeures l'échec de la lutte
contre il ya une recrudescence en stage
épaules c'est vrai parce que le grenat
breasseale à dos tellement large
actuellement que je mets ton et
puissante aussi à régler la crise
économique mais elle est une crise sans
doute longue durée parce que finalement
l'économie stagne et prospère qu'en
apparence elle est prospère à condition
pétales bien ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement
alors que le reste du monde se couvrent
le visage pour éviter le coronavirus les
pays nordiques ne juge veut pas
indispensable le port du masque suède
norvège danemark et finlande ont décidé
de faire différemment selon un sondage
yougov seuls 5 à 10 % des sondés à
danser et à 10 utiliser un masque de
protection contre 70 à 80% dans une
vingtaine d'autres pays suivi par
l'institut de sondage ensuite par
exemple pas de masque ni de confinement
le pays mise sur l'immunité collective
le masque n'aurait pas de grande utilité
à en croire cette externe en médecine à
nos finales de l'undd en suède
selon lui la situation est désormais
stabilisée dans le pays
aujourd'hui les statistiques sont
stables et les autorités de santé
publique l'ont toujours dit que le match
n'était pas une nécessité
notre épidémiologiste en html explique
qu'il n'ya pas d'études prouvant que le
masque à une réelle valeur pour limiter
une épidémie la stratégie du pays
aujourd'hui elle est également que les
citoyens qui sont par exemple malades ne
se déplace pas avec un masque mais
plutôt restent chez eux et pas une
solution miracle de les avoir dans la
rue je ne pense pas travaillent dans les
services infectieux à lund dans le sud
de la suède
nous avons alors aujourd'hui un patient
hospitalisé cause ducobu de 19 dans tout
l'hôpital
donc c'est une situation qui est très
stable je parlais également à mes
collègues de de stockholm la semaine
dernière qui disent qu'il ya un flux de
patients qui est extrêmement limité
qu'aux vide
le virus circule toujours évidemment
l'objectif n'est pas d'arrêter la
propagation total de ce virus car c'est
impossible c'est un virus qui est très
épidémique mais de contrôler cette
propagation qu'on ne pas être surchargés
et la situation est sous contrôle et il
n'y a pas de nouveau cluster observé
pour le moment et la belgique de son
côté renforce ses contrôles
elle a interdit hier les voyages non
essentiels vers un plusieurs zones en
espagne en suisse et en france avec près
de 9000 900 décès la belgique est le
pays qui compte le plus grand nombre de
morts dus kobe 19 par rapport à sa
population
avec 86 décès pour cent mille habitants
en direct de bruxelles on trouve entre
le journaliste et raphaël blanc d'amour
ah bon soir de nouvelles mesures ont été
mises en place hier désormais lé
vacanciers belges ne peuvent plus se
rendre où ils le souhaitent en europe
qu'est-il prévu aussi pour les belges
qui sont actuellement dans ces zones
classées rouge alors effectivement là la
belgique a interdit les voyages non
essentiels dans certaines régions
d'europe qu'à la création en zone rouge
alors parmi ces zones qui sont passés en
rouge depuis hier on retrouve des
régions au nord des régions au nord de
l'espagne dont celle de barcelone
il y a également le département de la
mayenne en france et aussi trois cantons
en suisse dont le canton de genève
très concrètement des touristes ont dû
faire demi tour alors qu'ils arrivaient
sur place et d'autres ont tout
simplement annuler leurs vacances
et puis pour ce que vous me demander
pardon à ce que ce qui se passe pour les
belges qui sont actuellement par exemple
en zone rouge
comme barcelone eh bien ils doivent se
mettre en quarantaine et devront pardon
se mettre en quarantaine est
obligatoirement se faire dépister une
fois arrivé en belgique et l'archos
facile pour les personnes qui souhaitent
elles se rendre en belgique et quelles
sont les dernières mesures aussi prise à
ces derniers jours pour les résidents en
belgique alors toutes les personnes qui
viennent sur le territoire belge pour
plus de 48 heures doivent désormais
remplir un questionnaire pour faciliter
le traçage en cas de contamination ils
doivent indiquer bien sûr leurs
coordonnées mais également les pays dans
lesquels ils se sont rendus les deux
dernières semaines et ce questionnaire
c'est un questionnaire qu'il est
obligatoire de remplir que l'on arrive
en avion en train ou en voiture
et puis ce qui se passe en belgique may
face à sorgues ont dû kobe 19 la
belgique fait preuve de fermeté sinon si
l'on puis dire par rapport à ses voisins
à bruxelles par exemple port du masque
est obligatoire dans plusieurs zones de
la vie
sur la côte et les plages belges le
masque est encore une fois obligatoire
et puis a ouvert la envers cependant la
ville qui concentre le taux de
contamination le plus élevé un
couvre-feu a même été instauré de 23h
jusqu'à 6 heures du matin cette semaine
merci beaucoup rappellent la blonde
amour journalistes à bruxelles
aux etats unis pressions et menaces
persistent sur l'entreprise chinoise tik
tok selon washington l'application doit
être cédé ou vendu fait afin que des
informations de centaines de millions
d'américains ne soient pas utilisés dans
le climat de tension politique et
commerciale avec la chine donald trump à
assure qu tic toc est utilisé par le
renseignement chinois à des fins de
surveillance
la compagnie chinoise a toujours
fermement nié à tout partage de données
avec pékin
ce dimanche c'était au tour du
secrétaire au trésor américain de
s'exprimer et selon lui l'entreprise ne
vont pas rester tel quel ce que je peux
confirmer c'est que parce que tik tok
acquis une société américaine elles
étaient soumises à la juridiction du
comité pour l'investissement étranger
aux états unis ce comité a fait une
recommandation unanime qui constitue une
alternative susceptible de forcer une
vente comme je les dis le président peut
également utiliser lieu au pea
il ya un large soutien bipartisan pour
ne pas garder tik tok tel quel sachant
que l'application peut transmettre les
informations et la localisation de 100
millions d'américains et horace aux
états unis direction en portland les
manifestations se poursuivent presque
tous les jours depuis la mort de l'afro
américain george clooney asphyxié par un
policier blanc en mai dernier
cette semaine encore des heurts ont
éclaté entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre
leur départ un temps évoqué donald trump
a finalement décidé de maintenir la
présence des troupes fédérales pour
ramener le calme
le récit de robes en cuir la colère ne
retombe pas à portland la ville du nord
ouest des états unis est devenue
l'épicentre des manifestations contre le
racisme qui dure depuis la mort de
georges floyd à minneapolis le 25 mai
dernier le déploiement des forces
fédérales par donald trump depuis le
début du mois de juillet
a eu pour effet de durcir le mouvement
surtout après la diffusion de vidéos
montrant des manifestants brutalisés par
des agents fédéraux
des heurts ont de nouveau eu lieu cette
semaine à proximité du tribunal fédéral
et d'autres bâtiments gouvernementaux
les forces de l'ordre russes fréquemment
de gaz lacrymogènes et de balles en
caoutchouc pour contenir les
protestataires
des pratiques dénoncées par les
manifestants et policiers n'auraient pas
dû faire du mal aux manifestants
beaucoup de gens ont été gravement
blessés je pense que c'est vraiment une
injustice sociale
les gens aiment jeter des choses mais je
ne pense pas que jeter une bouteille
d'eau équivaut à tirer sur un tas
d'autres personnes
je ne sais pas si vous voyez les
blessures ou pas mais j'ai moi même une
ecchymose à la jambe en ce moment c'est
à peu près aussi gros que de m'être fait
tirer dessus et je ne leur avaient rien
lancé j'étais juste là les policiers ne
se soucie pas vraiment sur qui il tire
ou de ce qu'ils font ce n'est vraiment
pas quelque chose qui devrait se passer
cette présence de trous fédéral est
aussi critiqué par de nombreux élus
démocrates
plusieurs maires de grandes villes
américaines reproche au département de
la justice d'avoir servi les intérêts de
donald trump en envoyant des agents
fédéraux en réponse aux émeutes
entendu ce mardi devant la commission
judiciaire de la chambre des
représentants à washington le ministre
de la justice williams bar a dû se
justifier
oracle chan nous craignons que ce
problème ne produisent des métastases
dans le pays
donc nous pensons que dans un lieu comme
portland
nous n'avons pas le soutien de l'état
des autorités locales
nous devons tient de position et
défendre ce bâtiment fédéral
elles naissent à atteindre un stade nous
acceptons ce type d'attaqués violentes
sur des tribunaux fédéraux
les autorités de l'orégon et le
gouvernement de donald trump se sont
entendus ce mercredi sur en retrait
progressif des agents de la sécurité
intérieure les troupes fédérales ont
évacué le centre de portland laissant le
maintien de l'ordre à la police de là
ville mais pour le président américain
pas question d'évacuer complètement la
sécurité du territoire ne quittera pas
portland temps que la police locale
n'aura pas terminé le nettoyage de la
ville des anarchistes des agresseurs à
trois mois du scrutin présidentiel la
question sécuritaire s'invite dans la
course à la maison blanche donald trump
tente de faire du maintien de l'ordre
dans les grandes villes démocrate
un argument de campagne pour sa
réélection
le monde arabe a désormais est lui aussi
une centrale nucléaire la mise en
service du premier réacteur de la
centrale de baraka s'est déroulée hier
aux émirats arabes unis
lorsque les trois autres réacteurs
seront opérationnels la centrale pourra
produire jusqu'à 100 1600 mégawatts
d'électricité soit 20% des besoins de ce
pays déjà bien fourni en pétrole des
besoins en électricité de plus en plus
important en raison notamment des
climatisations fortement sollicités et
selon riadh sidaoui directeur du cas
raps les autres pays de la péninsule
arabique devrait se mettre également
nucléaire le pétrole n'étant pas
inépuisables d'écouté il faut savoir que
le pétrole n'est pas éternelle ni pour
les ihm arabes unis ni pour le qatar qui
vient de critiquer la démarche imarati
ni pour l'arabie saoudite le pétrole
n'est pas éternelle donc il faut
chercher cette énergie alternative
propre et pacifique de tout façon il
n'ya aucune loi dans le monde qui
interdit l'accès à la technologie
nucléaire
les risques existent toujours avec
chaque centrale nucléaire dans le monde
l'a vu avec tchernobyl en russie on l'a
vu avec au japon c'est partout ici en
europe il ya un risque mais mais c'est
indispensable aussi afin d'avoir une
vraie énergie et propre rapide avec des
quantités suffisantes et il faut le
faire par en plus cantonné à la
technologie nucléaire aussi en avance au
plo progrès technologiques et
scientifiques et les universités les
chercheurs avancent et unique
technologie de pointe près très élevé la
posséder aussi c'est un certain appui à
l savoir pour la communauté scientifique
dans le pays concerné donc c'est un pas
en avant
moi je conseille tous les pays de golfe
de faire la même chose au lieu de la
fête
que les oies les oies et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve dans une trentaine de
minutes pour un nouveau point sur l'actu
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
je
vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir au terme
d'un imbroglio politique d'une
présidentielle
contestant les élections qui avaient les
observateurs la cedeao union européenne
et tous ces gens ont confirmé que les
élections nous forme de ces primes
démocratiques transparentes qui a gagné
c'est le général omar sissoko ballon
mais malgré ça